بالنسبه للناس الذين لا يملكون العزيمه او
حاولوا كثيرا ولم ينجحوا في انقاص وزنهم
ماذا تنصحيهم يا ريتا
انا اول شيء بنصحهن انه اكيد يكونوا
متاكدين انه جربوا الدايت يا اللي بتناسب
جسمه لانه اليوم نحنا بنعرف انه اذا كانت
الانسولين عالي في جسم الانسان يعني عنده
نوعيه اكل ما فيه كلام وهو لازم يكون
مقتنع انه على مدى طويله يعني يوم اغلبيه
العالم يلي بتعمل دايت وبتقول انه ما زبط
هم بيعملوا على فتره كثير قصير وبيحبوا
على حاله بيفكروا انه جسمهم بيقدر يتصلح
بطريقه كثير سريعه بينما نحن بحاجه الى ست
شهور نحن تنزبط هرموناتنا من خلال الاكل
اليوم انت اذا بتقعد سته اشهر بلا ما تاكل
نشاويات بلا ما تاكل سكر بلا ما تاكل كميه
هائله من الكحول مثلا همم مع الوقت راح
تتضبط
والاراده هي مرتبطه كمان بين النمط الحياه
اذا اذا الشخص عائش نمط كثير في ضغط كثير
في تعب حاطط الشغل اولويه حاطت الحياه
الاجتماعيه اولويه وين بدي يلاقي وقت لصح
هو يقدر يركز فانا هون بعتبر الاراده هي
ما لنا مرتبطه انه ولا انا عندي اراده او
ما عندي اراده لا انا او عم بساعد حالق
انه انا اطلع من هالنمط الحياه يعني انا
عايش عيش عيشته ده كرمال اقدر التزم بحميه
غذائيه معينه يعني مثلا في ناس بيقولوا
بما انه ما عنده وقت حضر اكل او اخذ همم
خيار صحي انا بطلب من دايت سنتر اكل كامل
جهزت ما يعلق عندك الحجه انه انا اكل هذه
على السرعه او على ضغط الوقت او مثلا في
ناس ما بتعيد تشتري عبايتها اشياء بتخليها
هي تنصح لان ما بتناسب همم
صحتها
الاراده ما في حدا ما عنده اراده وكثير
ناس بتعتبر انه انا ولا فشلت لانه انا ما
عند الاراده وهو بالوقت انه جسمه مريض
جسمك مش قادر بدايه
وياما اوقات بدايه كتير بسيطه مثلا تنقول
اذا بياكلوا الصبح ترتين ابعد خبز مثلا ما
جبنه ببلشوا نهارهم بطريقه غلط وهذا شيء
بخليهم كل النهار قبليتهم فاتحه على الاكل